we've all been there you really want to
go to a concert but the tickets are a
jillion dollars so you settle for nose
bed so you can still pay your rent and
sing some of your favorite songs amongst
other fans which is why concert movies
are the best the great thing about a
concert movie is that it provides
intimate looks at not only the
performances but usually what goes on
behind the scenes as well and there are
a bunch of great concert movies out
there with Beyonce's much anticipated
Renaissance on the horizon and the
latest Taylor Swift the AOS tour both
hoping to join this list very soon after
thrashing get pre-sale records so my
friends stand up and get ready to fist
pump just kidding no one does that
anymore sit down Steve as we bring you
the best concert movies all ranked by
Tomato Meter right now on Rotten
Tomatoes
countdown starting with numero 10
Rolling Thunder review a Bob Dylan Story
by Martin Scorsese well the title pretty
much tells you what you need to know but
I will see what I can do to to further
explain this 2019 film is actually a
pseudo documentary that includes the
usual non-fictional stuff from a doc but
it also includes fictional interviews of
actors playing different characters that
weren't actually on the Dylan's Rolling
Thunder review concert tour in 1975 and
what was that tour all about well we are
going to let Dylan tell you
himself the idea was to put a tour up
combination of different acts on the
same stage for a variety of of uh
musical
styles I wouldn't say it was a
traditional review but it was in the uh
traditional
um form of of a review that's all clumsy
bullsh you know I'm trying to get to the
to the to the core of thing to the core
of what this Rolling Thunder thing is
all about and I don't have a clue or
maybe he uh can't tell you but what I
can say is that scors goal was to look
back on the troubled Spirit of America
in 1975 while showcasing Dylan's more
joyful music alongside it and along with
the real interviews from Dylan and other
musicians like Joan bz some of the
fictional interviews are actually
performed by actors like Sharon Stone
and sure the name of this is super long
but critics say that it quote lives up
to its unwieldly title with a
delightfully unorthodox look at a
pivotal period in Dylan's career I mean
listen it's a pretty long title but it's
no don't be a menace in South Central
While Drinking Your Juice in the Hood
which is my favorite long movie title of
all time okay moving on number nine Dave
Chappelle's block party so this 2005
film follows Dave Chappelle during the
previous summer culminating with him
throwing a massive block party in the
Clinton Hill Neighborhood of Brooklyn in
NYC he brought out a bunch of great
musical acts like Erica Badu The Roots
Jill Scott Kanye and most de and Lauren
Hill was actually there too to do some
solo stuff but after her label wouldn't
release her music for the film she went
ahead and reunited with the Fuji instead
and performed with them one time one
time that was two times but I was
quoting the song sorry because now I see
that I'm killing you softly with this
bad joke I digress the concert also
featured comedy monologues and sketches
from Chappelle in between acts and you
know him just riffing all right man you
ready hit me hit me hit me two
times that's not how James Brown did it
his was crisp decisive I said hit me I
was like n
I got to get that James Brown Hit Me Two
Times that's better three
times that's right twoo from F NS that's
right and while a stage saw it share of
great Talent little did anyone know that
a young J Cole was in the audience
taking all that in for inspiration
before going on to become a big star
himself pretty cool number eight spring
scene on Broadway this film looked to
capture the intimate performance from
the boss's 23 36 Show run at the Walter
Kerr theater on Broadway in 2017 and
2018 it features The Man by himself for
the most part on guitar and piano
playing songs from his career and
telling stories from his 2016
autobiography Born to Run now
Springsteen also brings out his wife
musician Patty ski Alfa for a couple
songs which is so sweet for this show
that earned over $113 million from those
236 performances one night hanging out
Stone Pony and his beautiful redhe head
shows up she is a great songwriter she
is one of the loveliest voices I've ever
heard she is smart tough but
fragile ladies and gentlemen Patty
[Music]
scal you name the things that'll give
your life its meaning its purpose its
fullness it's it's very
reality this is what you build together
the movie was directed by Tom zimy who
had worked with Bruce on past projects
and also did a Johnny Cash documentary
once too so I got to know Tom who do you
like better cash or the
boss number seven Festival Express this
2003 British film documents the train
tour of the same name that took a bunch
of North America's most famous rock fans
across Canada for three shows Back in
1970 now this chooo featured acts like
Grateful Dead Janice Joplin the band and
Buddy Guy and if you're wondering how
anyone got any sleep on something like
that the answer is they did
not back could keep up with them man
they was poted all night long man I said
I got to go to sleep man every time I
went to bed I thought I was going to
miss something and I say well I got to
go back again and I wouldn't matter fact
couldn't never to stay in the bed for an
hour this train was not for sleeping it
was for a lot of other things but not
for sleeping very few people slept on
this train Festival Express combines
footage from the 1970 concerts in
Toronto Winnipeg and Calgary with more
contemporary Recollections from some of
those involved the the tour notoriously
stopped through a small town on the way
to Winnipeg where they proceeded to buy
up an entire liquor store Supply I mean
I guess that's what was feeling some
seriously cool train Jam sessions with
some of the most iconic musicians like
ever that's what I call
Locomotion number six
Marley this film uses archival
performance footage along with
interviews both past and present to look
at the life and musical career of Bob
Marley and it's told throughout the eyes
of some of the people who knew him
best
Z rules all creation he had a passion
everything I did with a ball he would
try to do
it he just didn't play for the fun of it
you this was part of the process you
know before he writes a song you burn a
split then you go run so you can Lively
up yourself and then you get more
inspired so the lyrics can come out the
project was supposed to come in 2010 to
go with what would have been Marley 6 th
birthday but things were delayed while a
couple of directors were attached and
then unattached kind of sounds like my
dating life in Martin Scorsese and
Jonathan Demi two names that are
Elsewhere on this list too now it ended
up in the hands of Kevin McDonald who's
also done docs for artists like MC
Jagger and Whitney Houston and what he
discovered is that there's pretty much
zero footage from the first 10 years of
Bob Marley's performing career I mean
can you imagine it's like that one time
I left my digital camera at a bar in
Orlando during college tragic I am still
not over it either way critics dug it
calling it quote an exhaustive
even-handed portrait of Bob with
electrifying concert footage and
fascinating insights friends can you
believe we've already made it halfway
it's kind of like an intermission except
I will be very sad if you leave so
finish up your bathroom and Concession
breaks and get back to your seats my
friends cuz it is time for the top five
best concert movies on Ron Tomatoes
countdown here we go number five David
Burns American Utopia this 2020 concert
movie was directed and produced by none
other than Le with David burn
credited for the screenplay so it's a
live recording of a Broadway performance
which was adapted from the touring show
that burn actually put together in
support of his American Utopia album so
it is a recording of a show based on a
tour that stems from an album got it
stay with me here it features songs from
that album along with other big hits
from Burn's career as front man of the
Talking
[Music]
Heads
theowing
again you may ask yourself how do I work
this you may ask yourself well where is
that large automobile you may tell
yourself this is not my beautiful house
you may tell yourself this is not my
beautiful he performed alongside 11
other musicians who were all using
Wireless or portable equipment and to
take it one step further everyone was
wearing infrared transmitters so the
lights could automatically track
everyone as they moved around isn't that
so cool number four the last Walts this
movie centers around the end of an epic
career for Canadian Roots rockers the
band after 17 years as a band now they
decided to hang it up with a big old
farewell show and they got Martin
Scorsese to direct the filming of it
epic the concert was actually held at
winterland Ballroom in San Francisco on
Thanksgiving Day in 1976 and listen to
this the audience of 5,000 was actually
served turkey dinners starting at 5:00
p.m. and there were things like ballroom
dancing and poetry readings that went on
before the band took the stage at 9:00
p.m. I mean this sounds like the
greatest wedding of all time and you
know that they played all the hits which
is probably more than you would think
throw them on your Spotify sometime
trust me like this
[Music]
one take a load for
free take a load off f
and you put the
on and they weren't the only ones to
take the stage considering the fact that
all the guests that they brought on was
like a who's who of rock gods I mean I'm
talking Dylan Clapton Ringo Joanie and
the Neals young and Diamond like what
the opening title card for the last Walt
says quote this film should be played
loud and honestly that's great advice
also Dream wedding guest list
number three homecoming a film by
Beyonce now this concert movie gives an
in-depth look at Beyonce's epic
Coachella performance in 2018 or as the
critics consensus simply put Bella
forever now it was written executive
produced and directed by Beyonce herself
and follows the show from concept to
Unforgettable moment in time and the
emotional road that it took to get there
considering that Queen be was coming
back from having kids and doubting
herself and you know a lot of the
choreography is is about feeling so it's
not as
technical it's your own personality that
brings it to life and that's hard when
you don't feel like
[Music]
yourself I had to rebuild my body from
Cut muscles it took me a while to feel
confident enough to freak in and give in
my own personality now the performance
includes three songs with her former
destiny child Pals Kelly Roland and
Michelle Williams and her husband Jay-Z
also makes an appearance which is just
epic now the Grammy winning film was the
top music doc on Netflix in 2019 and it
was also praised and honored by
countless organizations and people I
mean Michelle Obama even said the film
could quote Inspire the next generation
of History makers and record Breakers
and Sandra o called homecoming
viscerally inspiring during her toast at
the time 100 Gala I mean always remember
you have the same amount of hours in a
day as Beyonce
number two Amazing
Grace this film features ARA Franklin
performing gospel songs at the new
Temple Missionary Baptist Church in La
filmed over two consecutive nights in
January of 1972 now along with the movie
being number two on this list AKA it is
beloved by many the album that came from
it became the highest selling gospel
album of all time and I mean just give
it a
[Music]
listen we' got
come
together because we need the strength
the power and
all
[Music]
heing w we
hold we
can't the initial filming was shot under
the direction of Sydney Pollock and
includes MC Jagger and his Stones
bandmate Charlie Watts in the audience
at one point who happened to be in town
to finish their album Exile on Main
Street which like God I just love a good
Hollywood Story anyway the footage
didn't see the light of day until 2018
due to difficulties in synchronizing the
audio and video I mean did they try
unplugging and then plugging it back in
just kidding but alas Amazing Grace made
it to us and oh how sweet the sound and
finally number one stop making sense
this Talking Heads concert was filmed
over four nights at Hollywood's Pantages
Theater in December of 1983 while the
band was touring in support of their
album speaking in tongues another one
for the Spotify list now front man David
burn goes from being alone on stage with
nothing but a guitar to being joined by
a full band and then some throughout the
night eventually dancing around in a big
suit I mean you have to see
this girlriend that's better than that
she knows whatever she likes there she
[Music]
goes now the band raised $1.2 million in
budget themselves to pull the movie off
which contains some ultimately
influential uses of early digital audio
techniques nerd speak for it was way
ahead of its time director Jonathan Demi
may be known for movies like Silence of
the Lambs and Philadelphia but he's also
worked on music docs for artists like
Neil Young and Justin Timberlake and
it's no wonder because this one is 100%
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter with
a consensus from critics that says it
quote captures the energetic
unpredictable live Act of peak Talking
Heads with color and visual wi and what
I wouldn't give for a little more visual
wi well my friends we w rocked we rolled
we belted out the 10 best concert movies
keep your wristbands on for a while just
to remember us by for more on all these
movies that we discussed today be sure
to hit up rottentomatoes.com thanks for
checking out today's list until next
time I am your official groupy Nas Perez
and we'll see you back here for more
Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
countdown
oh